whenever I'm about to do something I
think would an idiot do that and if they
would I do not do that thing okay I am
better than you have ever been or ever
will be
unfortunately my feelings regenerate at
twice the speed of a normal Lance are is
among the most menacing of sounds that's
what they call it murderer and not
McDuck okay
always the Padawan never the Jedi
nostalgia is truly one of the great
human weaknesses second only to the neck
well these people here too many people
on this earth
we need a new plague how long you guys
been dating Jim couldn't land me in a
thousand years you look cute today do it
thanks girl
damn this isn't a shopping trip this is
a manhunt slash rescue mission okay I
just when you're done or any time it's
convenient I just thought since you're
out damn I'm obviously gonna get that
stuff for you so just shut up
how do I look normal ugly
I wonder if king-sized sheets are called
presidential sized in England I really
should have a tweeter account
what do you the diary they keep secrets
from my computer and you know what I
would like your undivided attention
please
you couldn't handle my undivided
attention I love catching people in the
act that's why I always whip open doors
you think you're excited you should feel
my nipples it can't mean that there's a
light he knows where he's going
machine
ah humor I have it too
diabolical plan I wouldn't even know how
to begin a day I found a copy of it in
the copy of Jerry yes I have a wig for
every single person in the office you
never know when you're gonna need to
bear a passing resemblance to someone
I hope the war goes on forever and Ryan
has drafted wait I'm sorry I said that I
didn't just part of me meant this is do
or die if he chooses correctly he'll
conquer the Hornets and if he doesn't
he'll die identity theft is not a joke
Jim millions of families suffer every
year Michael oh that's funny Michael
okay see you later pan
I don't care what Jim says that is not
the real Ben Franklin I am 99% sure when
two gay men have sex how do they know
whose penis will open up to accept the
other person's penis and I misspelled in
front of the entire school the word
failure Oh
do I miss you so much you say mature
when someone smiles at me all I see is a
chimpanzee begging for its life what is
the most inspiring thing I ever said to
you don't be an idiot
changed my life
you